go we're recording live from the ATC
pop-up podcast studio in downtown
Phoenix at the all things comedy
festival presented by Bud Light
cityscape and Tito's handmade vodka it's
the long shot podcast I just want to
point out that there's two comedies
there I know I missed one yeah all
things comedy comedy first I'm gonna get
yes folks welcome to the long shot
podcast I am your host my name is Shawn
Conroy with me today on the podcast the
passenger not the navigator in the front
seat Joe Wagner is here thank you so
much that was a fun time I had to do
nothing but stare out the window the
heat the man who lags behind but yet
arrives on time Jamie flam is here
pleasure thank you for having me
Phoenix and of course that's where we
are and of course the pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow miss amber Kenney is
here yeah yes yeah first wouldn't see a
round of the balance of the day a deep
finally a decent person to clap for she
has a third of audience a third of our
huge audience yeah we are in this room
with smaller audiences just so you know
really and it is a commission by the way
yeah name name folks we always start the
show some of the people here are
actually fans of the show thank you
thank you
others are here by obligation or love
familial ties right its obligation like
you know it doesn't get more obligatory
than that like sure I'll come to your
recital but we always start the show
with a segment we like to call checking
in so let's start today's segment
checking in with let's just talk about
our trip down here for a moment
or down here
I don't know what direction but yeah we
went out east east we drove very easy
drive from Los Angeles can I make a fun
related note a fun related note I think
as well here we go
or a fun comma related note comma okay I
always go with the commas my nan I said
okay so I heard about this go on and
very confidently drove West
Oh because as you know Phoenix is
situated on an ass hole in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean Jessica my driving
mate for the trip you're driving me yeah
my passenger just say my friend that
came my way my colleague navigator my
passenger all of the above
it's a new app Jaime's doing driving
right but she's like you're going
towards the ocean steer left steer right
won't you be my driving mate okay back
to you back to you okay so you are
literally headed west because you knew
which direction Phoenix right well at
one point we were driving down third
Street and because she was like oh
you're gonna take La Cienega not Fairfax
because Fairfax is good I know and two
it was like I love street stories yeah
[Music]
because three stories always take a turn
the new member of the audience is
shaking his head well Fez and I
internally go on
oh yeah what fozzy Anika yeah but when
did you realize oh and Jessica I said
hey what do you say just tell the story
we made on the spire no no she can say
for a fact she said Jessica she's all
about direction one time I was like I
think I'm gonna go south to San
she was like it's North North all right
so we drove down here Joe and amber and
myself six and a half hour drive yes how
was that for you guys
pleasant yeah it's great and we all we
all I don't think any of us expected it
not to be but it was the first time
we've all taken a don't know you don't
know what's gonna have a car ride that
long I'll be honest I'll be vulnerable I
was nervous
I thought maybe we would all hate each
other yeah I was I was it's a long time
to spend in a not a tiny space I mean I
think 2005 Toyota Corolla has plenty of
legroom so I was delighted by that you
and I you and I filled up that front
part pretty well I'd say the front part
the front part no but I was I was so
surprised with how fun and easy it was I
don't I say it was easy I wasn't driving
maybe you have a different point of view
but I want you know what let's start
getting props where props are due we
should start off with the fact that Sean
made a playlist for the road trip my god
true and on the road right so on the
nose that you can't help but grin
stupidly with it thank ya we are on the
road my favorite moment was when we were
on the 101 stuck in traffic in downtown
Los Angeles and John Denver's country
road it was just so not here's a city
choking on it so I've really take my
really tried to time the list out so
that it would hit the right places at
the right time but I [ __ ] that whoa oh
yeah we hit a huge snarl to get on the
freeway when the Muppets moving right
along yes which was Parfum in do Rock
come on right that perfect time nope
what's up
city but that's not a real song oh it's
a fictional world I just created that we
could have all entered you know what if
you listened to the show you know that
Jamie creates fictional worlds and that
is his life's mission you all know the
song India Rock India yes and we're not
gonna put that one on the album no I I
do know that you live in fictional
worlds in fact I was talking to some of
the other night and they were asking
about your theater and I said he wants
to create a world of comedy and
enchantment and this person was like
what do you mean by enchantment I go I
don't [ __ ] know we can agree it's
coming together but we'll save that for
later yes we will
I think in chairman's one of those
things you don't know it until you're
Indian Chapman right until you're
actually enchanted but here was one of
the lighting in the room so we drove
down here to Phoenix this is my favorite
part of the whole trip actually I'll be
honest this was my favorite part was
that I knew where I was going until we
got to Phoenix like we had you know
straight shot on the 10 all the way out
I didn't understand how we could cross
right from California to Arizona over
the Colorado River that did not make
sense to me
he kept saying what but we got here to
Phoenix and I had printed out directions
and I gave Joe the Joe just make sure we
make sure we know where we're going as
we get off at this exit and we got off
his exit and we immediately got lost and
meet like that first direction we had to
do I gave you Joe gave me the wrong
direction yeah I don't I was there's a
man here named Zach thank you so it was
I guess I I was shocked because it had
been so long since I had seen somebody
using directions off a printed piece of
paper I think maybe that's what threw
everyone well I had to copy them from
the lift
lithograph on the stone I had read a lot
well it was cuz I I said get off on the
I know what you said nor said it wrong
North ramp and it was South ramp well
get up on the South ramp to go on to the
north the street was north but get off
on the South South ramp and that's what
I meant you had one job and I'm Esther
day and but not even like you didn't
even take any time you immediately like
that was the first thing do you write it
was the very first thing off the freeway
but then I thought and tell me this is
cute right it's not no no no what I'm
about to say this part is cute then like
we got off the street I know what you're
gonna set it on the little side street I
thought it was cute and then I turned to
Sean and I was like isn't it great how
fast I noticed I made that mistake and I
felt - and Sean just turned and gave me
one of those Sean looks you know what
I'm talking about you know what you know
what he's talking about if you listen to
the podcast right one to anyone in the
back anybody else please anyone the
podcast please please is this supposed
to be recording by the way so we made it
we made it everything's fine sorry I'll
go into the trip can I ask a question
I'll never let that go yes
the sucks next what do we what do we got
no great question we stopped at a Flying
J that had one of those Wendy's Carville
situations
I was scared of getting angry hungry so
I had a spicy chicken sandwich some
french fries and a diet dr. pepper
that's alive I didn't have diet dr.
pepper that's what I wanted I had a Coke
Zero and a splash of dr. pepper okay two
crazy things about your beverage chaser
keep going had soft-serve ahead soft
Sean
like a long sausage you know how I like
my sausage it wasn't me long it was one
of those meat and cheese stick I just
wanted some protein like I didn't want
to like you know go crazy but I just
wanted some oh they're spicy protein and
then later I got some watermelon chewy
shards were not great they weren't about
pumpkin seeds didn't break into them yet
I know I saw some pumpkin seeds in our
room Jamie and I are roommates
here's a funny thing you he said angry
and hungry this morning before I left
can I give you a piece of advice by the
way cuz the second time you've done this
don't set things up by saying here's
something funny and then I going wait
for people to judge for themselves
here's something pretty compelling it's
that but there's a license plate on a
card said hang or hangry one or two
hangry what did it say are you angry -
angry okay that's not on that hang -
hangry one that's like I forgot that
there are some funny allusions made
about it and it's like if you aid if
you're that angry and hungry you have
some snacks in the car
just don't use the money to pay for that
vanity plate just buy some snacks are
you are you reconstructing a
conversation you had in the car on the
way down here yes okay just making sure
and that was where you real world were
you in the Sun in the car what do you
mean like was the Sun hitting mean what
are you trying to say are you trying to
say I'm a creature of the daytime I mean
the Sun it was there's windows I did
assume that there were windows on the
car they drove down yeah not I'm not a
heavy tent okay what are you going for
Joe like he was a little sun-baked yeah
I knew what he was going for I don't
know how okay also you sent an email I
told the the longshots gang that I
wasn't gonna be able to join them Friday
and you said in Spanish oh I said
something in Spanish
yeah I'm now I'm forgetting no hablo
espanol reloj a vaya con dios vaya con
Dios which means go
daaad right yeah I had never heard the
term go with God before until earlier
this week so the fact that it came back
again you never buy a conduce no God no
not in that context someone texted me go
with God and I was like what does that
mean folks you're listening to a
watershed moment in Jamie's life that
makes this a special show totally yeah
but you went with Jessica Kelly not God
we are all God's children hey so ain't
that the truth
so anything else about that trip well I
was a little so I'm sorry I was gonna
say I was I'm always a little
self-conscious on a road trip I was
telling Sean earlier because I I I feel
like I get very quiet like I'm not I'm
not naturally talkative welcome to the
podcast but but I because I tend to zone
I really tend to zone out on road trips
and just I just love the passing images
of the countryside and then it's like
you just you come off as like a creepy
side yeah I know I was sitting there and
I was going god dammit I wish Joe would
say something this is so awkward no I
know but that's just it's a it's it's my
own thing you know I know neither of you
were ever feeling like that but at the
beginning I was like you know oh I felt
like there was a couple of hours of very
tense silence in the car was intense but
you know there's a time where it's like
there's always a time on a road trip
where everyone in a car realizes like
now it's quiet time but that's a good
time right when there's three people's
less awkward than two though oh that's
fair right what do you what do you what
are you saying to me
where there are some very oh that
doesn't seem like that I'm glad that
knows you know they were too busy going
what about hangry this angry that we
angry for six hours
hey yeah
Wow we had we had some inside jokes
there's like Halloween people's this is
like really weird what's happening Sami
they're zombies literally looking into
the pop-up studio right now where's
Brandon this is a picture yeah it was a
good Instagram moment yeah
all right so checking in on the road
trip is done let's go next on to Joe
alright alright Thank You Zach Joe yeah
I know a hand we're going on thank you
let's give Joe a hand for going first
going first all right
um we already checked in on the whole
road trip thing but I don't want
personal check-ins beginning now when
starting Rochelle so Sean and I were
talking about this earlier but we
recently there was a recording of the
show and and if you're a new listener
then maybe you listen to that show maybe
you want anyway there was recently
recording where I in telling a story I
am gonna be very discreet about this you
guys know but in telling very much him
and I thought it was back then too but
you were not no discreet well I was
specific but I don't think I was graphic
graphic right we're a little graphic for
some um it is an adult show for people
who understand language yes you were
graphic so I like to thing that I paint
a picture but anyway it was graphic okay
so I I recently in telling a story I
divulged something about someone who
I've kept anonymous the entire time true
totally anonymous but I divulged
something about them that if if they had
if they were to hear the podcast they
could be very embarrassed by what I said
right
and so serve idli so absolutely anyone
would naturally have that reaction
because it was embarrassing it was an
embarrassing thing and and and I told
the story and I struggled a little bit
with it before we tape but in the moment
I made a choice I made a decision it - -
full speed ahead - talk damn the
torpedoes full speed I talk about it
because I think and there was I think
that was just a part of me that wanted
to truly tell the rest of the story
life is full of surprises it'll throw
you a curveball that was the whole point
of the experience to me not really
specifically what I was saying about
this person anyway that's the setup
what's happened recently and this is
something I've never quite experienced
with our fans before is that some fans
were very upset yes by my taking that
out they felt that it was unfair to the
person there about whom you divulged
this private information a violation of
I think it's sort of trust yes trust and
and so I wanted to bring it up because
there were something like I said some
fans of ours on our Facebook page we're
discussing it and I've read all those
things and I've been thinking a lot
about all those things
um it caused quite a kerfuffle there was
a little bit of a kerfuffle but that's
because we've we've all talked about
this like none of us sitting up here
likes confrontation some people do I
mean most people don't but I mean but
some people can get into it I am
basically I step back from it as much as
I can and and in this case I I've read
everything and I don't I don't want to
step back from it I just kind of wanted
to take it in
I appreciate our fans expressing their
opinion I completely am grateful to
actually I I knew that was the risk I
was going to take this be like a press
conference anybody was offended by what
I said I'm not saying I'm not saying it
I'm certainly I would never say phrase
it that way if you were offended I know
people were offended I know that I did
something that that pissed some people
off and they thought that was the wrong
thing to
and I'm absolutely been taking that in
and I just wanted to say I appreciate
the podcast art former at a festival
that's pretty much celebrating it's a
different way of communicating it's a
different way of sharing personal things
about you and if anything what I'm what
I've been thinking about recently is
that I may have really in that moment I
just did not think about how a podcast
goes out - you thought of it is just
having a conversation because that's
hold onto talking into microphones with
a bunch of people watching because
that's ultimately what we do is we just
have a conversation with each other and
to that point
Sean you brought this up early if you
want to mention it but I don't know no
throw me under the bus it's the facts
about you making the wrong turn when we
got off the highway no but did you
notice how quick I caught that yeah yeah
I'll make up for the fact that you still
[ __ ] up hey you know what I'm only
human I just wanted to say that some
people if you're a listener and you
think that we the way we do the show we
vet what any one of us is going to say
we don't do it we just let ourselves
either walk into the fire or not and and
in this case I think I did in a way and
and I I just thought that I trusted I
trust these guys enough to be able to
talk about that but as far as those
those repercussions I just wanted any
listener to know that I've been thinking
about thinking about that and how I
regret I I regret it I regret it you
regret having you talked about that
stuff yeah I regret it I think I you
know what I played a certain risk that a
person will not ultimately hear
something but in the social media world
I don't know if that's ever not gonna
happen you know and what happens if this
person does hear this there would be
they would be mortified mm-hmm there
would be mortified because it was just
something it was something biological
with something about the primary all
right I'm just saying
come on I there goes discretion out the
window just looked out and I saw some
people starting to look off into space
like I don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about so I just wanted to but
you regret having discussed that openly
on the show yes fear that the person you
were discussing will eventually hear it
even though none of us have any idea who
this person is it is still a completely
anonymous person right so what they
could hear it and be upset that you read
this reaction right right so anyway but
maybe they'll take care of their issue
their biological all right gene okay you
know what
yes things can thinks can pass and
sounds like she was constipated that was
go back to what you were saying just
because I want to make this clear you
wanted to talk about this and that's how
our show works like there's I know
there's no I mean yes I sometimes tell
Jamie to stop talking about snacks but I
can't help my there's no there's no
vetting there's no vetting of like no
you can't talk about that on the show so
it's not like right we get together
beforehand and go alright let's take a
vote on what everybody's story is gonna
be right so to say this was a bad
decision by all of us that's right he
has one even involved in that that was
me in the moment I was joking with Joe
before saying like what if I imagine if
I said to him no you're not allowed to
talk about that
like and now I wish you had but yeah no
I am I think it's just been I wanted I
would say to put a bow on it I would I
think it's very interesting that with
podcasting and social media I think
we're all in some way learning what
about what boundaries are like
redefining some boundaries and I feel
like as humans yeah I feel like I
stepped over a little bit in terms of a
privacy thing again you went too far I
think that's how I'm feeling right now
but but I think it's been great for me
too I
think anything that makes you rethink
you know sometimes it just lets you
reset and think about those things
because I was saying to you guys on the
road trip up over the years yeah oh
Jesus I hope we get to the silent part
this is quiet me no I was telling we all
have comedy friends comedians who we've
seen on stage do a bit and every now and
then you go oh I know who they're
talking about they're you know or like
like you know but it's still in a noun
it's like it's used obviously for comedy
in this case I just wanted to tell the
story but III just thought I'd kept it
anonymous enough and I hope I did I said
but that was not that was not the issue
was whether the person was anonymous or
not it was like should this information
you should even be yeah
and and I'm not that again I'm not the
kind of when I've seen comedians do that
I always cringe a little bit cuz I go of
course you immediately go oh am I gonna
be a part of somebody's act a lot of
times if you you go out with it and
start going out with the comedian
you're a are you gonna talk about me on
how can you not do that well which is
part of like I think again in telling
stories about life I set up by the way I
set up this story what the episode I'm
talking about was part two like I really
set it up and and there was a part of me
that felt like if I don't talk about
part two it's just gonna seem yeah I
don't agree with that though because I
feel like there would not have been a
lot of people listening to the show who
would have been like what the [ __ ]
right but what happened no I know but
I'm thinking more about if I were if I
were listening to the podcast I would
have wanted to hear but you would have
already known but in another story
another universe in Jamie's world and
Jamie's the world he's created so that
so so anyway no I gotta get one other
point on that is that it is your story
like it is an experience that you had
and I'm not saying you should have
talked to
but for people that say you can't talk
about that I don't agree with that
because it's an experience that you had
and that's all we have right and I
honestly for anyone who heard the
episode I honestly was trying to talk
about it in a way that did not
alright well you failed in the night I
did I I know I I was really constantly
trying to talk about it in a way that
would not hurt somebody but I realized
that that was me rationalizing in the
moment that was a failure
oh here in the room has heard that
episode Chuck all right well a few
people here have after hours this is
just good promo we're all about the
ratings in podcasting tuned in last time
sorry what were you going to say ah I
don't I think that you pride yourself on
the fact that you really didn't do it in
the spirit of making fun of her shaming
her right I think it may have been just
a too much information situation right
but you weren't you you could have done
it in like a you didn't I might have
overcompensated in the other direction
by being medically accurate
I was trying she was trying to because I
saw a couple eyebrows perk up by being
medically accurate my somber press
conference with Amber's great line all
right
Chucky's name let's go next to Jamie
whoo great to be here thank you thank
you for me but yeah I'm walking the room
go ahead Jamie his loss ga'head ga'head
okay so I'm my life my life you can't
pay attention
what's going on here because there's too
many people going in and out all the
time there's a lot of thank you I meant
on it every time all that's gonna do is
point it out more there was literally
zombies before like no that I agree with
because I couldn't see it and I turned
around I was like damn I wish I had seen
that right owner anyway so I [ __ ]
love them well we talked about that on
the road yeah the undead my favorite
yeah he loves those in general or just
go on with your checking up I remember
when we went through the whole periodic
table of the elements and how great some
of the neon you know the gases are I
thought you said you liked Tom B's and
you weren't so into vampires did not
happen during those silent parties Joe
was just making up conversations and
it's heavy muttering Oh a whole other
car remember when you said you like
potatoes but you hate Tomatoes I'm sorry
so go ahead Jamie so on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday I so on the
last episode I announced that I'm the
biggest project of my life is happening
[Applause]
the classic one man standing No thank
you so much it's like the tomb of the
unknown soldier all right well so I'm
opening a new comedy arts venue in Los
Angeles and so announces the world
unless episode and then this last
Tuesday we launched a Kickstarter as a
way of promoting it and it's a
membership drive too it's a whole
concept for a membership driven comedy
arts music theater and we're saying a
lot of words they look quite falls
seasonal seasonal membership this whole
thing and so it was this putting it out
to the world in a huge huge way right
it's like a scary crazy thing this thing
that's been a secret listeners podcast
that I for a long time
I mean a year really and so now the
world knows and it was like I don't know
know if people understand how much work
goes into a just a Kickstarter it seems
like I just throw some stuff up but
figuring out those rewards we were up
till 4:00 a.m. getting that video edited
and getting it just perfect and then
putting out to the world and so you were
up till 4:00 a.m. on one night to put
this whole thing because up till 8:00
a.m. oh well yeah but I guess I'm saying
if you're up till 4:00 a.m. to get your
Kickstarter video edited before you put
it out yeah you probably should have had
a know I mean this was a week before
that night so eight can I ask you what
some of the rewards are can we like plug
some of the rewards like what did what
were you coming up with I mean they I
mean one point we had butler service at
this place but that that's gonna be at
phase two or phase three okay you get so
if you're thinking about not getting a
reward its butler service that you won't
get like what is he something happens
and he gets arrested he has to be
someone's but oh that's right
interesting
Seinfeld welcome to the film recap so
what are the fairlane dances weird
go on Jamie so so the first day we got
two amazing pieces of press and LA
Weekly and las américas articles what
did I say pieces of press pieces of
press yeah pop pop who needs one word
when you could have three several pieces
of press so then on the first day we we
got up to like 10,000 were asking for
$100,000 which that's a lot of that
that's a lot of money and so now we're
like four days and you're surprised by
how much you're asking wow it's so I've
never had that much money I mean what
it's like if you ask somebody for a loan
and then
I'm asking you for so much money right
right I think if you were gonna do this
like what's a reasonable amount to ask
for what about 250 now that's too much
right I think a hundred thousand is our
sweet spot but for you it's like holy
[ __ ] we'll be rich that it does I mean
will so now we're at 20,000 as of today
which is awesome that's great but that's
20% but then like 80,000 80 percent yes
that is so much more and so ok so some
rewards we have a reward where you can
you can get a limousine ride to a boat
and then get on the boat spend the
afternoon on the boat and then get the
limo ride back to the new theater and
catch a show what if you just want to go
to a show I like that if you just want
to go show there's plenty of options for
you do it but a boat trip and a limo
ride and I just found out that someone I
know who was my car mate has a plane so
we're gonna maybe sweeten this deal with
a plane ride to the limo so you got it
to get a limo to the plane limo to the
plane fly up you jump out of the plane
land on the boat take the boat back to
shore the limo meets you there takes you
to the show
boom done and that's enchantment folks
if anyone knows a parachute person that
could be a thing if anybody knows a
parachute person by the way why does
airplanes I don't like flying I'm not a
big fan why don't they build the plane
above the clogs but why wouldn't
everyone be equipped with the parachute
it seems like just such an easy thing
every seat has a parachute if something
happens you all just like being on a
ship and everybody has a lifejacket
great analogy thank you perfect analogy
thank you it's like on a submarine
everybody has a snorkel and on a plane
everybody has their own life jacket and
on a parachute everyone's got a oh so
the new theater that I'll be running
it's very exciting what else can I talk
about
oh here's the funny thing so I'm a
businessman now right this is a new
phase where I have to be a businessman I
would be careful about the way you talk
about this as if it's a crazy weird plan
you're absolutely right as I'm raising
money I'm telling you right the sketch
of Jamie getting a bank loan I'm
expected to keep books now and things
like keep truck jumps pending I'm just
gonna be a lot transparent as I always
am on the show but it might cost a
couple rewards but uh I literally went
into two banks and a credit union asking
for a loan turns out it's really hard to
get a loan if you don't have income so
that's a fun fact and if you're looking
to cause the crash of 2007 yeah so armed
with nothing behind them Jamie's car
mate laughed the hardest at that because
she's a business side I do have business
people so just don't fret there's people
that know that numbers were due and
they're guiding me but so I know you're
starting to get into some trumpian
territory I do have business and I also
feel like Jamie's like being on a ship
and the captain's going alright man I
know it looks bad but there are some of
you on board who know what you're doing
so just do your thing you know who you
are I hope you know who you are
step up I am playing up the character I
have on the long shot a little bit
that's great so you're making it happen
I had to hire the first two people right
one was a graphic designer and a
branding expert who's putting together
all the branding for this thing and then
my car mate who did she suddenly become
anonymous we've mentioned her name I
know five times Jamie's just weird
go on Jamie Jessica Kelly's in the room
discreet and medically inaccurate
she's a comedy manager she has a plane
there's there's so many things I've
learned about her six hours long time
she makes jewelry she makes costumes
what are some other things I don't all
right Jamie we keep talking about your
thing so and she was the other person
like she's a paid employee that's
helping me get through this Kickstarter
the next three weeks there's so much
work that you have to do to like just
it's a job right and I need help and so
but the negotiations between these two
people could not be more polar opposite
the graphic designer was contracts and
lawyers and really getting the very
business the very business leveraging
stock numbers and then Jessica we hit we
negotiated so I'm just gonna harm eight
my karmic that's on our business card it
is speaking of which I got [ __ ]
business part cards I mean I spark in
pay you don't have to pull them out it's
a broadcast no I'm gonna put over here
for the people in the room oh oh there's
cameras yeah those things those are
cameras so I paid 50 bucks have these
rush-ordered for this festival which
arguably was not money both donating to
the Kickstarter now you know where the
money is going okay this has become a
disaster for my future which is
unfortunate please I mean hey it's a
great tease I think we're keeping the
t's going contribute to then two weeks
ago Jamie days up till 4:00 in the
morning so the negotiation with Jessica
was it was just I wish all negotiations
can be like this because you know I'm
learning how to do this kind of stuff
and I was I like to design Jamie isn't
it great it's got kind of an art deco
thing
yep right explain up to the architecture
of the place right and the history of
the place and so this was I'm gonna do
my best I said - oh she was like make me
an offer when you know what you can pay
so I made the offer for I was like you
know I don't have any money right now
what a great offer I'll take it I'm
higher but at the end of this campaign
there will be some here's what I can do
X dollars per hour mm-hmm she said I'm
gonna sleep on it and then she said I'm
just trying to be better about did did
she go to sleep right there yes it's the
way you able you just kept going I just
imagined her head going down and
sleeping for like 20 minutes and then
she answered you that's not exactly what
happened right I didn't really hash tag
she said yes well so then she said so
I'm trying to be better about I got it I
got to think about this before I just
jump in there's things I want to do and
you know you have to take care of
yourself and make sure you're getting
what you're worth then she said well
here's what I've been thinking about
number wise and I said let me sleep on
that you guys are like paradise by the
dashboard lights like let me sleep a lot
of sleeping involved what's the
difference between what I offered it and
what you just said you didn't understand
no I mean it was like you know there's a
gap and you have to figure out like
ultimately what is that number the
difference she said the difference in
you guys pushing papers back and forth
and going back to sleep
alternatingly going to sleep take a look
at this
[Laughter]
let's be grateful on those animated
podcast things where they have like you
animate the things that are happening
hey somebody out there and what else I
made this
find a parachute so what happened so you
met in the middle I'm guessing so then I
was like how about we meet in the middle
of that and neither of us sleep on it
and then we just laugh seven days and
then she's like deal deal and it was
just like we just laughed and it was so
joyful and it was like we just did a
business deal and never heard of a job
negotiations that involved you can't
sleep don't sleep but it worked it
worked and I'm happy I'm slave-driving
her it didn't mean to bring slavery into
this just as please donate to my
campaign this is for the future of
comedy it's gonna be good for everyone I
promise no slaves please don't I gave
you a no slave guarantee hashtag joined
the dynasty Jaime don't sleep on that
alright well congratulations on Angry
Men sure I hope it goes well it will be
good for everybody if it does and we'll
see what happened thank you but let me
sleep on it alright we're tired up at
the bottom of the ninth ran on third
remember that whole phil rizzuto thing
all right amber checking in hi amber
yes amber can you give it up a bright
light yeah she didn't get him oh nice
took a kneeling of it Mary woke very
woke very Game of Thrones I like that um
I
last week was in Moab Utah nice end of
second I
[Laughter]
on my first Wotton offer family vacation
there's a Liz so connected deep breath
about Amber's family trip with the
boyfriend so you went on a trip love
your family with your boyfriend's family
correct right for the first time very
frog yeah you you get to see family
dynamics in action I'm close and it's
always interesting not being a direct
member of the family because you maybe
see things they don't because it just
becomes right the air they breathe it
also pointed out things about my family
because you just think that's how people
are until you see something else
oh we do things differently we do things
the right way
[Laughter]
shoutout to Uncle Jim Aunt Shirley thank
you for the best
oh so on this trip little things like
okay this is all the the players
involved it's Jeff's both of his parents
both of his sisters it's gonna be okay
his nephew who's 10 and then his
sister's boyfriend sure how many car
mates we are all each other's kind of
one big car me and we had a minivan so
all of us except one of his sisters and
her boyfriend came down separately later
so we were all in a minivan and we
landed in Salt Lake City and drove from
Salt Lake City to Moab which is four
hours in a minivan like so it was a
family vacation
like it's so hardcore and when we got to
Moab the first day we were walking
around I also was just hungry angry
maybe maybe we should eat maybe we
should eat and everyone like okay like
so we'll walk around for an hour more
I'm like the least squeaky wheel right
so we land in Moab we're walking around
I'm starving and they find one of those
storefronts that's just like a tourist
trap of all the tours you can buy in the
tourist City and they sit there in the
lab in Moab so it's like you can see
this rock this rock or this road you
could go on like a ziplining tour or a
dirt bike or rent ATVs or right jet ski
I don't know I don't know what I'm
talking about but I'm very cool so they
proceeded to go into this storefront and
read all of these brochures trying to
decide what they wanted yeah and it blew
my mind
because my parents would have picked out
what we were gonna do weeks and three
months ago right so your parents do it
the right way no it's better just was
like we're here we're supposed to be
doing vacations I'm not deciding but
some of those brochures I mean the
photography is so dynamite some of the
just the the copy is it can be tell a
story
evocative evocative that that brochure
in and of itself is shout-out to
brochures or has any other podcast
giving a shout-out to brochures yet okay
the hippest podcast in town
hey flyers we love you a pamphlets [ __ ]
you keep doing what you do and by the
way I'm talking about the tri-fold brews
you're in the marketing game so you're
looking at these brochures we decide on
zipline tour the mom didn't want to go
definitely adamant so we were trying to
think of something everyone wanted to do
but that wasn't gonna happen
and finally Jeff's sister took me to
this site because I was like no let's
make everyone happy
I like making everyone happy kind of a
problem I have but I didn't and was like
mom doesn't want to go mom wants to have
four hours without all of us around like
this is what she wants she wants to have
us go and her not go and I was like okay
good as long as we're not leaving
someone out we went on the zipline to
her it was so it was my first time
ziplining and it's like flying you go
really fast not know you could adjust
okay like how far your body is away from
the zipline determines how did anybody
not get all the way up to the next thing
Trent
yeah the ten-year-old like they kept
telling him like Trent buddy be
cannonball because we don't but shoot
Nate so one of the tour guides was this
guy Nate and I was obsessed with him
because he we found out later that he
normally just answers the phone at the
zipline tour place and this we didn't
know what he was doing no this wasn't
the first time they're letting him go
out on our tour but he was just like
like a golden retriever like so excited
to be there and like the whole time like
Moab ziplines how can I help you and
like the other guy the other tour guide
Scot he has done it a lot but Nate was
laughing too hard at all of Scott's
jokes that you could tell he just says
all day long and they was like oh and um
my favorite moment he was just very like
Shaka bro at one point Jeff was like oh
mate told me that he's hung out in
Riverside California and I was like yeah
of course he has like I don't
explain it is that is that like my
aircon diarga yeah but I was getting
into my apparatus on one of the zips and
he's like hey you Jeff's old lady
maybe my age right and I was like yeah
and he's his reaction was that's what's
up
[Laughter]
but like you never hear the phrase old
lady anymore unless you're in a
motorcycle game right exactly
so he was wonderful and I loved him an
animation for Nate and then how was the
how was the mom's reaction when you got
back from ziplining was she like crying
by herself like she was like I made
dinner what was for dinner
Jamie always asking a hard question
now when you say teriyaki do you mean
teriyaki because the blood people don't
know that a traditional teriyaki is much
different than what has become here in
the stage I don't think I mean
traditional okay the next day we went
hiking in Canyonlands and we went to see
this old ancient Pueblo where they store
like an ancient food pantry that was
carved in the side of like the pyramid I
thought just like it and and it was cool
and the whole family was there and then
we didn't know if it was a round-trip
trail or if you had to turn around and
go back and I was like I think it's
round-trip but it was just like the side
of a mountain and I was like I could do
it and like I climbed rocks a lot as a
kid
so I I was feeling real proud of myself
and I was just on this rock my ankle
goes I fall on both my knees and mmm and
I like to slide a little bit
I could have slid off the entire
mountain and
Nate just pops up he touches you I wish
[Laughter]
so Jeff's 10 year old nephews just like
running around and I I find a safe spot
and I sit down and I cry for literally
ten seconds like I just was like okay
let's get off this mountain
um because I want I wanted to leave
before my knees were swollen I couldn't
do it I just needed to be freaked out
for a second because it was just so
scary mm-hmm and his mom was so
concerned about safety like she didn't
like anyone even being close to the edge
of cliffs
nobody likes people bellows to the edge
of cliffs except for the Wylie the
roadrunner when it comes to this but I
just seriously injure myself on this
trip his mom will hate me forever
she will blame you for [ __ ] up the
whole trip and ember as you were telling
you there wasn't nobody saw that well
Jeff saw it
Oh Jeff saw okay but at least it was it
was that thing sometimes when I think
this is one of those things that happens
when you fall depending on whether
anyone sees it or not like like you said
like you just had the moment of like I
just have to suddenly cry this out that
I was scared but when other people are
around are like are you okay you okay
and then everyone was like hey are you
all right and I was like yeah I just
need to not be hysterically sobbing when
I see your parents again and do you
think it's possible that she would have
blamed herself if you had hurt yourself
yeah no she's wonderful I thought that's
just my weird mm-hmm but my knees are
pretty banged up that's why I keep
wearing pants they're really I was
wondering about that I was like why is
amber wearing pants a little weird oh
you want to show your knees to the
camera oh oh
we have cameras here to show you're
right this is just the Jaime cam that's
like right who's watching this by the
way what is this keep asking questions I
don't know who are you we're in some way
we're being held hostage but like I had
to ice my knees that night and stuff and
then a bunch of family drama went down
and I'm just sitting there with good
times for everyone I went on I went on a
trip once with a girlfriend and her
family we are still so immature they as
a podcast anytime we've mentioned any
relationship we've had and I know we so
we went we were in Colorado Telluride
Colorado and the dad convinced me that I
should try snowboarding he was like
you'll love it you just got to get the
hang of it it's and I know how to ski
but I don't know how to snowboard he's
like it's great you're gonna learn
you're gonna love it it's great so I
went I rented a snowboard I got on the
hill immediately snapped my elbow
backward broke my elbow and so I went to
the you know I had to had it like bring
me down the mountain and go to the first
aid tent so I was intense swing and then
but but it was the opposite it was like
the mother was cutting my meat for me
because I couldn't use my hands then I
was on painkillers and we went out to a
bar that night and my girlfriend said to
a guy who was hitting on her she was
like my boyfriend is right here and he
will kick your [ __ ] ass
and I was stoned out of my mind and with
a broken heart so it was not good but I
guess I'm just saying like it's not
necessarily that they're gonna blame you
for it it could be the opposite I just
didn't want it was maybe the person
causing trouble yeah I went to Palm
Springs with my girlfriend and I was
[ __ ] great congratulations and her
mom walks in and limping leaves in there
and just kidding medically accurate
I would Jamie's yes and just go horribly
awry into a hardcore threesome yeah with
a mother and a daughter oh hey do any
other fictional world that I created I
have a question do we do any of the
rewards for the Kickstarter include like
time spent with you I think there was
one out-of-town package for I think for
longshot fan right where maybe there's a
Skype conversation with me because I'm
thinking I'm telling you I want to write
no but that's the thing I am truly about
five thousand dollars to have a Skype
conference I will take that I know that
there are people out there listening
right now or have listened to the show
who would who would want to spend time
with you like to see to like shadows to
see if you're really the way you seem I
think though I think disappoint but like
in the story that obsessive so I put a
q-tip in my ear you guys are missing a
great story I put a q-tip in my ear when
we get to Palm Springs in their place
it's like her whole family and her
sister and her sisters husband and her
parents and one thing leads to another
and one thing lead generation or Jace
that's your universe no it's not
no it wasn't an orgy it was me I'm
pushing the my earwax deep going into my
ears oh and it plugged
your ear and so that was my kind of
snapping my elbow or following him very
much was like I couldn't hear right for
the entire weekend I was just at the
table like just deaf in one year and
that's really sad smiling and nodding
yeah I was the boyfriend who just had a
q-tip X that deserved a paltry
single-class it actually happened again
in my life up in New York City
oh I was in Harlem where you lived at
one point nope nope I lived in New York
City I didn't live in Harlem I worked in
Harlem oh I knew there was a Harlem same
deal like a q-tip accident and you
didn't learn your lesson the first time
I do not use q-tips exclusively now what
else do I use I just take a little tip
with a longshot tip you take a one
square paper clips
definitely don't work do not [ __ ] with
paper clip right they will puncture they
will bleed you will not hear in
different ways than just the q-tip if we
do not use paper clips take take one
square of toilet paper tear in half
dip the DVD by the way folks I didn't
catch that at home it was did a little
bit of creativity and I get that with
the toilet pass all my hair in and you
get a waxy situation do you not clean
your ears I'm not blessed like like Oh
Jaime immediately starts peering into
Amber's ears right there wax free from
oh I can tell all right well it seems
like we've come to a part of the show
called parting shots so let's do that
I mean you should stir sure I'll start
parting shots here's my parting shot
thank you that yes yes thank you
I did two shows last night at the Tempe
improv hello which was great
super fun it's a great club there's lots
and lots of people at both shows first
show I would say was five hundred people
maybe four maybe three hundred fifty
twenty that's a really that's a real
comedy club yeah it's a big space with
lots of people in it both shows were
very crowded and it was super fun but it
also made me realize I want to be a
better comic because it's a club and
people have certain expectations when
they come to a club which is the way the
show is supposed to go and I'm so used
to doing the rooms that I do which are
more sort of alternative spaces and you
get a little bit more room to stretch
out and not worry so much about when's
the next joke when's the next joke
when's the next joke and that's what
they wanted last night and they also
didn't really want to which I don't
blame them for they didn't really want
to do a lot of work of making
connections and some of my jokes you
have to like go oh I see what he's
that's the kind of joke I go for is not
a laugh but more of like oh I see let me
sleep on it but really there were a
couple jokes and there was one joke in
the first show that just didn't work at
all and I was like okay that joke always
works and didn't work and I get why it
didn't work right and then in the second
show there was a joke I wanted to do and
I said to somebody before I went on I
was like I'm gonna do this joke because
I want to do it but I know it's not
gonna work for this audience and I went
on and I did it and it didn't work for
that audience but see I told you that's
what I said when I came onstage
I was like hi I went again but what was
also nice about it was I came offstage
after the first show and I didn't feel
badly about how I did I did I did fine
you know the set was fine but there was
something in the back of my mind was
like because everybody else there on the
show was a real Club comic and there was
a part of me that was like
am i you know I don't know how to say it
but like I'm not as strong as some of
these people in this particular
situation whatever so I'm sitting there
I'm at the bar by myself which is the
the title of my autobiography and I'm at
the part of myself and Don Conroy walks
into a bar one of the one of the waiters
comes up to me and just goes hey man
that was so [ __ ] funny and like
shakes my hand and I was like that so
cuz from a waiter who's in the room all
the time
he's so much it was very like I was like
oh thanks like it really meant a lot was
very meaningful to me so sometimes the
universe smiles on you and you should
all smile back did you smile back at him
no I was like by myself no it was very
nice of him all right
parting shots let's go next to Joe okay
I think my parting shot is gonna be
about the fact that this is a discussion
that we have been having since we've
been here in some form or another which
is there have been a couple times when I
know amber and I have looked at each
other while we've been here and we're
like why are we here I mean specifically
its first of all and I it was just it's
gotten me thinking about how Carl Sagan
used to go on and on about questions
what do you mean Joe no the idea that I
guess you know what it is I think it's
that for us the podcast has been such a
thing that we kind of just do for
ourselves
it's very insulated from the real world
us meeting a chance every Sunday morning
to record us talking to each other and
then like oh that's right we're a part
of a podcast network and their other
shows and that we know some of these
people and and I want to thank the
festival I think it's been a lot of fun
super fun and but I just wanted to
remind us that I feel like you wanted to
remind us of this I wanted to remind us
that every now
when we have that instinct to be like
what are we doing here it's like well
we're here so we're meant to be here I
think we always deserved it we all love
to undercut ourselves and I think that
that's what our show is all about I'm I
am happy and proud to be a part of this
podcast I was invited that's a part of
that Network and I'm ready to be a part
of this festival and it's been really
fun it's my first trip with the guys and
yeah that's what's up that's what's up
I'm feeling very grateful and positive
and it's been a lot of fun Joe Wagner
everybody Joe Agnes parting shot you
heard it here first on the long shot
amber parting shots a week from today
November 4th will be the second liquid
feet dance class whoa Jamie's car mate
maybe there she was at the last one I
know
oh cool um and so so what does that
entail the liquid feet dance class um we
teach a warm-up we do some across the
floor and then we teach a liquid feet
original routine to the to the our
friends that we may - what kind of music
um
that's always a fun surprise last time
we did a Ke$ha song this time it will be
something different studied all the
Kesha song it would not be worth it
won't be a Cassius ever looked at us
after saying now with the dollar sign in
her name okay but no longer hmm she go
to the dollar sign yeah why so go to
Amber's dance class this this will come
out after this will it or won't it hmm
but she'll be talking about the people
that come out ya know how much fun I
think it won't I think it'll come out
before something November right that's
what I owe ya
that wouldn't happen find on that that
would have changed the whole complexity
or we are professionals yeah so yeah
November 4th like with feet and then we
have another show at UCB I forget the
date just lots of liquid feet coming up
community we're working on a good of
liquid feet dot no no website and I
think we have one oh okay I'm really
good at this
great we're being on a Christmas ballet
I'm very pleased that stage my rep for
ballet oh I have to make some calls
after this what if the liquid can be no
Nutcracker I don't see why not I don't
see why not even I don't either
all right Jamie parting shots okay we'll
start with I also have like I said
something on the last show that's
created quite a stir not quite as much I
I mentioned on the last show that I'd
spent Oh amount of money on a big league
chew
yeah thousand dollars I'm not a
financial position dollars buying
bubblegum you are asking people to
invest money in you and you invest your
money in big league
it's got brilliant branding what
brilliant branding it's like you feel
like you're a ball player I'm especially
in the World Series I
it was a world I created that just went
over everyone's head I created a
universe where I would pay a thousand
dollars for big league - so you didn't
actually do that is that correct I did
not pay a thousand dollars for big
league chew
you heard it here what is wrong with me
I know it may amber literally brought
that up in the car on the way down why
did Jamie spend $1,000 on big league
chew and I'm saying right now it's been
a Kickstarter for ninety nine thousand
dollars without the big league chew
yes anyway big leech I did as a kid it
was so you
I have $1,000 worth of big lead you know
you're telling the listeners that you
made something this changes everything I
don't know what it is up and what is
down the big leagues your thing with Amy
is there a theater there's a theater and
I'm gonna use this opportunity right now
to if you're watching this live right
now a heartfelt plea I have a dream to
change stones you just appropriate as a
giant so oh right now tell them you
don't have a dream you know what I have
a dream to enchant the world to bring
people together through comedy and arts
I'm being very earnest right now are you
or is this like the big league chew
thing this is the big league chew thing
might end up [ __ ] me because this is
real if you go online right big league
it's a classic flam thing where he was
joking but nobody understood that he was
joking when I add we all took it serious
you called me out for not committing and
I was so committed but I don't get how
that was the Rhett words that the rest
of the day were you like like even in
retrospect I'm like that's not funny
funny I was going for you were just
doing an acting exercise yes Jamie like
later on in the day were you like they
bought it they bought it no not until I
saw many posts and emails about like
what's up with Jamie the big league chew
meanwhile I was like of course [ __ ]
Jamie has a thousand dollars worth of
yeah it shopping accepted it immediately
how much big-league to that is I assumed
that it was very valuable by the packet
so maybe you got three that each cost
three hundred and thirty three dollars
and 33 and a third cent now I thought
that you had bought like a palette of
but back to contributing to my dreamy
weight just to keep going with this
I actually justified it in the car yeah
he was like no no it's good yeah I was
like that's just Jamie like he thinks
that kind of [ __ ] is funny like a bunch
of big league chew is funny too
hate it makes a it's whimsical that's
whimsical yeah it is pretty ones its
enchantment that's enchants yeah yeah
why not okay speaking of enchantment so
if all of the fans of the longshots
contributed hundred bucks and I want to
say this not we're actually we have a
patreon coming and I did not want to
take any money out of that for this
podcast but right now late but right now
let's make this about me and my dream
which will make a beautiful place for
this podcast for liquid feets Nutcracker
or sweet rising tide lifts all everyone
went on and all along stop friends and
gave let's say just a 100 bucks you can
give more or less whatever you have
helped us make a place in LA for
podcasting for amazing shows and a place
where we can have a hub where
enchantment for the world can exist what
do people get for a hundred bucks the
out-of-town package you get you get a
subscribe back you get an amazing
dynasty typewriter notebook pencil your
PIN and maybe a t-shirt I'll tell you
what next five will come in you will
throw on a t-shirt 100 bucks for a
pencil
oh and anvil livestream oh and we'll
livestream at least two shows for you if
you're out of town and and I will get vu
tickets with you to come to LA go to
dynasty typewriter comm for all the
information invest in my dream I'll sell
you this pencil for $100 look sounds
like the beginning of a fable elderly
people at home it's like those [ __ ]
FoxNews commercials where they're like
you need an upside down oh wait wait and
finally is there anyone in this room oh
god yes there are people in the room
that would like to come up here and
share a nugget of wisdom Jesus change
some come on up some sort of guiding
principle in your life that helps you
get
this if you're a new listener this is a
tradition of the show where Jamie asks
our guests if they Jamie puts the
responsibility for a parting shot on
somebody who's here as a guest so that
he doesn't have to do it now this time
he did have stuff too but right Zack is
here to give us I will be one percent
honest I was saying I was like Oh
Jamie's gonna come he doesn't have
anybody to ask a question to so I was
like maybe I'll ask the audience this is
a dream come true true right it's just
an honor for us to be able to provide
this moment for you thank you
it is an honor so my thing would be but
wait first you have to tell us who you
are
oh you're I'm Zack race also from Tucson
I don't know Amber's family but we put
from the same place yeah hey now you
guys will pass each other on the street
and pretend you don't know we had a
terrible but Dec you are somebody who
was listening to the podcast before oh
yeah for a long long time I can give you
the wrong directions if you are yes it
doesn't do a lot it's been a big
influence in my life so I don't take the
opportunity to thank you all like you
guys I saw this honor that you guys have
saved my life like this podcast 100% the
only thing I can laugh at for years
thank you but I wasn't my brother's job
I'm a hard shot was even if it's really
really hard always be honest with people
because that'll make you grow that that
made me grow and like it's really hard
and most people will appreciate it so
yeah from Tucson Arizona
so da hood no I'm crushing it I've seen
your name you popped my cannon ders I
said you may be more monitors yeah yeah
that's smart guys ever seen $100 pencil
you like that dogs out you know and love
the thousand butter Sharpie you can
erase it from this end and write with
this end I know I know we're going on
real quick I never have anything to plug
I just want to plug real quick out there
the Joker's wild on TBS
it's the game show I worked on it's
hosted by Snoop Dogg it's airing now
[ __ ] oh wow I would love anyone who
listens to the show to check it out TBS
The Joker's wild it's airing now enjoy
it thank you very much yes yes Joker's
wild please check you want to say a
special thanks to stand-up live the
Tempe improv and Chico Malo where we had
lunch today
great was amazing really good delicious
thanks to our engineer Aaron rung guard
give them a hand
thanks to the wonderful staff here at
the all things comedy festival give them
a hand
Jack is here and there are lots of other
people involved and Jill Z Zack and
Maury mark Zack and Victor and Victor oh
you made it sound like they were staff
oh no that's what I thought you were
doing is listing more oh yes thank you
guys for coming to the show bill burr
and al Madrigal over now magical for
putting the whole thing together thank
you to all things comedy thank you all
for listening and watching the long shot
we'll see you next time tonight
[Applause]